immigration figures for the year 2021
have been published by the Ministry
from the inside
here are some important points
that is in the report
already the report repeats several times
that immigration flows to France are limited
this conclusion
it is illustrated by several numbers
7 7 years ago
of the French population
which is composed of foreigners
a foreigner is a person
who does not have French nationality
the france rate
it is below average
of the countries of the European Union
which is 8 4
it is also inferior to the Austrian
to Germany or Spain
who have much higher rates
the report also states that there are 10 3
of the French population that is immigrant
an immigrant
is a person who was born with a nationality
foreign in a foreign country
but who lives in France
47 5 of these immigrants come from Africa
knowing that the three most represented origins
in metropolitan France
it is Algeria
morocco and portugal
the share of immigrants in the different departments
in France it is very variable
more than 20 of the immigrants live in Île-de-france
to highlight the fact that France is a country
where immigration flows are limited
the report also takes the example
permanent immigration flows
therefore flows from abroad
that can lead to a permanent installation
in France
france is part of one of the countries of the ocde
which is one of the rates the
lower in proportion to the population
the fight against illegal immigration
there is an increase in arrests
that have been pronounced
but also an increase in removal measures
for 17,000
people in an irregular situation
have left French territory
which is a level that predates the results
that there was before covid
on the other hand
the number of non-s is increasing very strongly
since he took 56
in 2021 so here it is
one of the main conclusions of this report
is that now
migratory flows into France are eliminated
and that France
can no longer be considered
as a country of massive immigration